foreign
[Music]
hey guys and welcome to yet another
episode of congratulations
[Music]
dude I gotta start making some better
faces in the podcast I know that like
you know I'm the face King but I'm
saying dude I gotta start making better
faces to mess with this dude so we can
pause on him and you can be like what's
this episode all about so here goes one
dude and we'll use this as as the
thumbnail
congratulations no that's not good how
about like this
there we go that one's killer dude
um so yeah
um what's the deal you know that's what
I'm always thinking
uh uh
I'm shooting my special April 1st in
Minneapolis Minnesota
chrysalia.com I'll be in Austin Texas
I'll be in Midland Texas and I'll be in
uh different places you know I never
actually pull the schedule up and I
should pull the schedule up when I start
but I and it's it's respectful that I
don't do that because I'm me and what I
do is respectful for you because I'm
giving you me oh yeah I'll be in Irvine
California oh they actually that's sold
out Brea California Oxnard California
uh just doing the test run there oh
Milwaukee's the one before the special
March 31st
and uh Columbus and Cincinnati which
I'll be there I'll be in Boise and Salt
Lake City
Utah
ah just silly with words sometimes you
know my son says noculars instead of
binoculars he's got binoculars and he
keeps saying inoculars and it's cute and
um my nanny's like cal It's binoculars
and I don't want her to be doing that
because I want to hold on to these years
because I want him to be saying noculars
because it melts my heart but um
anyway uh feeling good today uh well
actually was feeling not so good at all
you know some days you just wake up
dread City for some reason and then you
you try to focus on the positive at
least that's what I try to do and then
uh and then you watch a few clips of
stuff online and I watched you know a
little clip of golden hour the other
podcast I do and I saw Eric and we were
talking and on the clip he wasn't
talking to the mic got pissed off tried
to relax all good dude still a friend uh
but he wasn't talking into the mic and I
was just like come on buddy and uh but
yeah but then I came home and the
organizers that my wife hired
it's too much money all good but she did
she hired them organized this podcast
room and dude let me tell you
it's just a whole new world in here it's
amazing we pushed the desk out now it's
a small room push the deck desk out I
got more room back look how far your boy
goes back I'm touching the wall now so
that's crazy
um but I feel good and on and I even get
rid of isn't even here right now it's
just one fire and I and so it's like
it's like dude this is Fit For A King I
got my whole I might start twitching
again you know I gotta set up
so uh so yeah uh was out and about
wearing a live ripped shirt uh hoodie
you can get that at chrisley.com just
promoting that life rips lifestyle uh
and uh people were like yo life rips and
I was like hell yeah do it and it makes
me feel good when people do that
um and uh you know woke up with some
dread today rip roaring no medication
you know just the you know the
prescribed obviously the daily from my
OCD
but that's and also I take finasteride
for but I've been taking that for a
decade and that's for you know just in
case my hair
goes away but uh it's okay my hair's
looking good I I you know dude uh
so like And subscribe we love it pump
the algo and um
the volume Pump Up the Volume uh pump up
the algo whatever doesn't matter it
doesn't matter you know I could say that
or not say that
but I did oh cow's crying I wonder what
happened
um so yeah so I finished the last of us
did it because felt like I should
because everybody's talking about it and
Pedro Pascal copied my drink at
Starbucks
bleep that out bleep that f word out
it's too early to use the f words in
this podcast
um but yeah dude uh got the same
Starbucks drink order as Pedro Pascal
people are saying yo what that says
we're both equally is famous it's like
people what the heck Christie rips off
page because Pascal I'm like nah dude
it's pretty Pascal that's ripping off me
you get my
espressos
so it's like I see you dude
um so Peter Pascal has got a good head
of hair speaking a good head of hair uh
and he's good in the last of us another
the the girl is good in The Last of Us
uh good actors you know but then I'm
like the show's fine like I watched the
show and I'm like it's fine
and then I'm watching the show for six
episodes and I'm like it's fine
and then I'm like it's okay and then I'm
like oh every episode there's like three
episodes where if you like legit just
take them out it's the same show and you
did only Nine episodes it could be a six
part mini series
because like there's that whole episode
where the two uh homosexual lovers God
bless them we love them you know at the
congratulations uh podcast at super good
uh Studios God bless them you know they
get together and God bless him you know
um
and as a non-binary you know which I am
like I watch the the thing and I'm like
well God bless him you know but did they
need the episode and as a non-binary
person I'm like well does do we need
that one God bless him but do we need
that episodes and no like I love having
it having the Gaze in television all
over the place I want them doing
everything I want them doing the craft
service with some little cupcakes with
the sprinkles on it you know uh like a
light you know maybe like a salad you
know light snacks because gays are in
shape and we love them even if they're
not but we love them but they're doing
craft service they get a nice spread you
get the boom guy holding it you know
what I mean
uh another take like we love them
the boom guy sound guy ah shh the
chair's creaking we love them so
um
but what but you know but then it's like
that they had the Standalone episode
where the two
we find out the sexuality of the of the
girl and it's like okay you know but
that was a standalone little episode as
well and then people are like but these
episodes are great and I'm like yeah
they are great
but it's like do we need him so then I'm
watching it so I'm waiting so episode 7
comes and there's Nine episodes and I'm
like okay all right all right okay and
then episode eight comes and I'm like
okay right so this is how you watch okay
and then well and then episode nine
comes and you're like
okay so this is these are the this is
these are the the ways you these are the
emotions you go through each episode of
The Last of Us you go like this
episode one okay
episode two
okay episode three
all right
episode four
okay
episode five
okay episode six
okay
episode seven
episode eight
okay
episode nine
and that's like basically the gist of
The Last of Us
so by the end it's good
now everyone who's like yeah it gets
good to all these shows that you could
stream you start with the show and then
it's like you gotta watch a few episodes
okay but then you watch Game of Thrones
and everyone is just like you gotta
watch a few episodes or maybe even the
whole first season so I'm like how many
episodes do I have to be like okay until
the thing is okay right so I watch Dude
I watch Game of Thrones how many
episodes are in Game of Thrones of
season 10 12. I swear I'm just like okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay every episode okay okay for
three four seasons until finally I'm
like okay I'm done with it
so at least the last of us got to okay
by episode seven of the first season and
now we'll watch the second season cause
I'm done with the okay I'm done with
those shows right
and that's my review for The Last of Us
and pretty much all the HBO shows
um
anyway dude
and that's how reviews should be
honestly I I should review shows and
movies with what okay is it that's it
dude we figured it out man dude that's
what I'm gonna do
okay
that's the last of us that's how good it
is ask me another movie what did I see
recently
um oh I saw that movie with
um Morgan Freeman and uh Cole Hauser
Cole Hauser and Morgan it came out and
apparently here's the ritual killer it
came out in 2023 it just came up and
Cole Hauser was there in the thing and
then Morgan free moves on the the [__]
on the thumbnail and and this is my
review of the ritual killer okay right
so you know how good it is dude the most
succinct way to review a movie Yes we
figured it out okay
too low wish it was louder so uh yeah
anyway that's how it goes
glad we came up with that new system
um
so I'll be watching uh season two of
that and am I am I am I a Pedro Pascal
fan yeah I'm a Pedro Pascal fan you know
uh am I uh uh Betsy Willis what's her
name the the the little girl in it the
the one with the
you know I I I don't know yeah she's
really good in it apparently she was in
Game of Thrones too as well and um but
she's in the new The Last of Us and I
you know it was weird when I first
started I saw the whole thing about how
because I played a little bit of the
game because you know I I I I I I delve
into it a little bit sometimes but the
video games and whatnot and I played a
little bit of it and and uh Ellie was
the character right and um and she's and
I Ellie and the actress looked nothing
alike Ellie in the video game and it
actually looked nothing alike and
honestly neither does really picture
Pascal doesn't look like the guy either
but I don't care about that stuff but uh
people were like in an uproar about that
and then now they all don't care because
she's so good so anyway dude the last of
us really cool man and uh the ritual
killer not so good anyway uh but I will
tell you dude I love the director of the
of the uh of the ritual killer George
Gallo he is an awesome dude
um and uh and that's that really about
my reviews and all that stuff you know
uh but I want I want to you know I
talked about a little bit about this on
on Lifeline Pedro Pascal is great and
that's it okay so let's stop talking
about Pedro Pascal talked about it on
Lifeline with my brother done with that
conversation
um but uh yeah I I I I you know I have a
I have had a good week
um and I I was like you know what I
really okay so I had
um
I had a St a week where first of all
everyone around me
was getting sick just everyone my whole
family
um Lulu one of the people I travel with
uh Enrique my tour manager just everyone
was getting sick my brother just so many
people were sick
and you know your boy
just
I mean
Johnny immunity really like I get I have
great right like it's great okay Johnny
emergency
and so
that's really just sugar we all know but
um
so I
I'm good and I'm coasting dude and I'm
just coasting through it everyone's got
sniffles and I'm just I'm Johnny coasts
a lot right and um
Wednesday comes along no it's Thursday
comes along it's noon my daily uh
therapy you know I do therapy a lot but
uh it's my this Thursday it's at noon
don't want to do it don't want to do
therapy just don't want to do it just
straight up don't want you know like a
kid is like don't wanna
like I said to Calvin the other day I
was like you wanna uh
you want to oh oh I said can I borrow
your binoculars and he just goes like
this no
you can't
I'm like
being a kid is awesome because you could
just do that and not offend anyone right
but if someone's like to me like if I
was like Calvin you liked his shirt and
he was just like no I'd be like
but if a if an adult was like no I'd be
like okay well that's fine I mean we all
have our own [__] and it doesn't matter
what you think
it's deeper so
um
so uh I'm talking I'm I sit on the couch
therapy is at noon and uh it's 1205 and
I'm just not clicking the zoom link I'm
just you know what I'm doing sitting
them downstairs my wife's upstairs I'm
like I wonder if Kristen would be upset
I'm not doing my therapy but I'm just
instead I'm just sitting you know what I
can do pretend to forget
you know what I could do pretend to not
know what time it is
all good
my wife walks downstairs sits on the
couch we have a conversation it's 12 10.
nearing on 12 15. my therapist texted me
I'm on and I go I see it and I go
yeah
maybe I'll just kind of like
conveniently forget so then my wife
stops talking in the middle conversation
she says don't you have therapy and I
say oh you know what yeah actually
um I am getting on here a little bit
that's why my computer in front of me
she says okay so I get on
and she walks out obviously and I get
I'd start talking to therapy and I'm
just
just mentally just blah now how do you
feel your feelings that's a whole thing
like I don't really know I try to feel
my feelings I really didn't even know
what
you know shame and guilt and Dread was I
know what dread was but like for the
past three years been working on feeling
my emotions and all that now this isn't
going to get sappy at all uh but I'm
talking to my therapist and how do you
know how you feel your emotions and
that's what I've been working on and not
being defensive and really being open am
I okay with fear am I okay with sadness
am I okay with insecurity and all that
stuff and acceptance and I'm talking
about therapists and it's just Dragon
dude some sessions drag
some sessions you go in and this thing
of the tears wipe dang of the dang of
the tears wipe dang it dang of the dang
of the tears tears tears wipe wipe dang
it a dang it and you're rolling
and some you're just like okay it's like
you're watching episode three of The
Last of Us you're like okay
and
so I'm watching I'm doing I'm you know
zooming with her and it 12 40 comes
along and she says
what's going on and I said you know I'm
just not feeling it she says you look a
little uh
not
well like you're like white and I'm like
you don't know me or I'm just a new I'm
like a new color I'm like translucent
I'm like the color of off dead you know
what I'm saying and she's like
are you sick
and I'm like it was like the scene in
Goodwill Hunting when he was like that's
not your fault or what is that is that
what he says it's not your fault and
Matt Damon's like
I know I know I know
and and uh
and she was like you're not sick and I
was like no no
she's like really I was like yeah
everyone's a sick everyone else got sick
but
she's like oh okay we start talking
every few minutes and she was like I
feel like uh maybe you know I'm dragging
it out of it today and maybe we can we
can end early and I'm like really and
she says yeah
I said uh yeah maybe I don't know I'm
just kind of like whatever she was like
are you sick again and I was like
no I'm I'm not I feel good I feel fine
it's just kind of like
down you know
we start talking we're wrapping it up
and she says
you're sick Chris
and I was like
you think that I'm like sick like I have
something
she's like yeah you don't feel good and
you're run down
and it's okay
and I was like
yeah
yeah you're right I I am actually sick I
think
and then she said well take care of
yourself and we hung up
and that's when I realized
I was sick
my the here's how
[__] up in the head I am
my therapist is diagnosing me with a
cold
do you know how [__] up that is that's
how
much I compartmentalize my [__] is that
my mental doctor
is telling me I need to take Dayquil
dude
do you know how the level of [__] up
you have to be in your head
to have someone who's not a doctor who
physical doctor
to tell you your mind won't let you
realize that you got a bug
is just on another level okay
so the next day I felt awful
and that night
I went to bed early
and the next day
I still felt bad dude if I just decided
I was sick when I got sick I felt like I
would have been better already but my
mind was playing
you know how the rest of that goes
be honestly how stupid can I be
so I got off the the zoom and Christian
was like how'd therapy going she's and I
said yeah I thought like I was having a
tough day mentally and struggling but my
therapist just said that I was sick and
I should get some rest she's like oh
cool
the good thing is dude I I really do
feel like I'm like branching out and
doing things and like becoming a better
like a more well-rounded person I mean
dude I would have never thought ever in
my life that I went to I would go to
Dave and Buster's and not only that want
to go but I did
okay and the reason is well first of all
you know my wife is like this person who
God bless her she's my angel and I love
her but she gets an idea and then wants
to do the idea immediately even if it's
like
hey let's set up a scavenger hunt
tonight and I'm just like well that
requires so much to do and she's like
okay then let's fix up an old car with
what we would have to get it I'll look
at the back pages and I'm just like whoa
you don't know what that entails
you know she'll be like they're oh
they're having a uh you can rent a villa
in uh
uh Aruba uh May 6th you want to go and
I'm like it's April 1st
you know
it's April sick it's April 6. we gotta
you wanna she's like I'm gonna look and
I you know what I already talked to the
business manager and I'm just like all
right well can we can we just can I I
didn't even hop on the train you know
what you did you did the thing where Vin
Diesel just uh is in the car and then
opens the door and skids and and Scoot
you scooped me up like that like you
scooped me up like your Tyrese in in
[__] Fast Five and you just you don't
slow down you just skid out open the
door and just and scoop me up and I'm
already on and I'm like what do we I was
just having a sandwich
outside of an Italian deli and you just
you know Tokyo drifted by me
you're Luke whatever his name is that's
in that was in Fast and Furious three
and then they fired him and now you're
in NCIS lost in New Orleans and y'all
talk like this who's that guy Luke
who's a cow talks like this on NCIS
Luca
Luke Lucas Lucas
Lucas black dude
I don't like how he said Lucas Black
like it's yes obviously because I said
Lucas and that's the guy on it you know
and so um
so so so so so she says so Mizu which is
her college team and and you know she's
in a small Sports more than me which is
not much but you know her when she went
to Mizzou and it's nostalgic for her and
they made the playoffs or something
right
the top 16 or some [__] which isn't it's
like a lot you know it's like basketball
is the only sport that'll be like
so dude they made the top 48 and you're
like what
call me when it's five
yeah dude and the team's never heard
it's like yeah but fair found fair
amount walkerfield is dude the the top
seed and you're like really what seed 29
and you're like that's bad
you look at the Players they're all like
tall white guys this is not they don't
deserve to be here
what's up and so she's she's like oh
great news guess what and I and and she
texts it to me and I'm like oh I'm
uncanceled
and then she's like
and I go oh Mizzou made the top 16 right
64.
are you kidding me how many teams are
there yo here's the deal there should be
honestly
20 teams
60 they made the top 64. that was what
you wanted to she's over there watching
me right she's right here but so I'm
like but here's the deal so she's like
Mizzou made the top
64 which I didn't know so she says so I
get home I get home and she was like
I've got I've got it I've got the I've
got the idea
and I'm like what
and she says
Mizzou is playing tomorrow in California
Cal has never been a basketball game
it's my team
let's go
now
what did you notice in that sentence
because I'll tell you where my man my
mind went right away
a dumb guy would be like
hell yeah
when do we have to leave I don't want to
catch traffic
but a smart guy dude is like
she said California
's big she made it seem like she tried
to sneak in like oh I would she tried to
play it like I was gonna think it was in
LA right
like you might as well have said like
North America you know like to gonna
play on this planet
and so I'm like oh okay where and she
said it's our state we gotta go and I
said yeah but where and she says
Sacramento and I go I'm too smart for
this game dude
no
hands down
right just
and and then what else do you want to
talk about
from now on that has nothing to do with
what we just stopped talking about
and she's like uh well come on it'll be
cows first game we could go fly up
tomorrow stay in a nice hotel and I say
there are no nice hotels in Sacramento
and I know that because I've been there
a bunch of times
and she's like well we could stay in San
Francisco and then drive and I'm like
dude this is an ordeal and also no hands
down
did we forget about that and she's like
but it's my team this has never happened
before and now just now I figure out
it's the top 64 teams
you know and uh and and so I'm just like
we're not doing it
so
we don't do it
and that's cool but then I'm like
wait a second the next morning I wake up
and I'm like dude
you can't even fly anymore she's a
hundred months pregnant
and she's like she and I didn't even
have to have the argument I became the
bad guy and now I gotta like cater to
her feelings because I said no when in
actuality I could have just like put
science on her and been like well you
know you can't fly she'll be like oh
yeah you're right I would have been good
guy
she tricked me dude
women be tricking dude
so now she got me because I'm bad guys
she's like let's go to Dave and Buster's
and we'll watch the game and I'm like
okay and I actually kind of want to
right because like I'm like Calvin will
have fun at Dave and Buster's and I want
to see his face look at all the video
games and all that
that's 100 degrees in here and um
yeah where's the uh why is it so hot
this this now now this time where's the
remote for the thing
oh
so
shouldn't be 100 degrees so that's cool
it stopped oscillating
oh God so anyway
um
so anyway I I she's like let's go to
Dave and Buster so I'm like okay so we
go to Dave and Busters and I'm like
let's invite whoever
we invite you know Rick Glassman Brent
Morin
uh uh one of the guys from my tour
company and then uh we invited you know
David Sullivan came because he's always
he's American sit still and he always
wants to be a part of everything and
he's got a big fat head and uh Kristen
and Calvin and we went and we got there
and uh
and no we didn't invite we didn't invite
one flyer uh because we figured you
wouldn't go anyway and so
you would have went wow that sucks damn
okay well now I know he would have went
so um
I was you know by the way David my
friend David he's one of those guys
that's like hey when are you going to uh
Dave and Buster's because I gotta go see
my son sing in a choir at five but the
game's at 3 30. I'll be there and you're
like what for how long
do one thing
I don't get people who drive from spot
to spot like I'm friends with King Batch
this [__] is I mean whenever you
see him it's the ninth thing he's done
that day
it's unbelievable dude you could catch
him at 8am and he's like hey man I'm
about to dip actually because uh I I was
just at my friend's uh Coffee Spot and
then we went to a brunch and uh I gotta
go to this opening of a Fry's
Electronics and you're like what what
are you this is the ninth thing you did
today
I was with them the other day at the ice
house it was like [__] 11 p.m 11 30
and he was like all right man I gotta go
my buddy's in John Wick four we gotta
celebrate uh this is like why did you
come here
um I don't get guys like that dude if I
go out that's the thing
next stop snoozeville
it's unbelievable dude it's dude I don't
even want to pick a friend up that's
another spot I gotta go to I want to go
right to the place and ride home dude
sometimes I want to go to the place and
then I'm like I just want to live here
everyone out
but um so I get to Dave and Buster's and
David's already been there for like 20
minutes which is hilarious and he's got
his cowboy hat on and I'm pissed at it
you know and uh and we're at Dave and
Busters and Calvin sees Pac-Man bigger
than life and he is just so in it he is
so in it dude
we're walking around he's like I'll play
that one and I know I'm like this one
you you won't like but all right let's
do it and then he's like I don't want to
play this I'm like I know it but all
right you gotta figure out for yourself
and so you know Rick Glassman is killing
it at a poppy shot is that if that's
what it's called I don't know he's just
basically like mini basketball and he's
doing so well and stuff and then
we get to this big thing and I'll post
the video of it I put it on my Instagram
I put on my reels page I didn't post it
on the create or whatever the hell you
say
um
and there's like you know those those
those things that where you push the
thing and you're with the claw and you
try to get the Pokemon and then it gets
up to here and then it drops and you
never get it there's a huge like
adult version of it like where it has
huge stuffed animals and it's taller
than me I'm a tall drink of water I'm
six two at least dude right right when I
look up in the morning I'll probably six
three and
um
it's got It's so big that it's got like
a door to go into it like that that the
the maintenance or the workers go to put
the stuffed animals in
and this dude
walks up and I said look Calvin do you
want to play
and this dude walks up and he looked
like the second person that gets killed
in the movie Species with Natasha
hinscheritz and he says uh
hey watch this
and opens the door to the big
claw thing
and steps inside
and I don't
I'm like I'm pretty sure he had a
lanyard on which means he worked there
but maybe I'm doing the thing where
later on you're like you've witnessed a
bank robber robbery and you're like yeah
he had a mustache and then you see the
crook and you're like why did I think he
had a mustache I have no [__] idea
basically this what I'm saying if this
guy worked there or not but in my mind I
made it to where he has a lanyard but
maybe I just made it to where he has a
lanyard
because of the confidence he had with
walking into a thing which I think I
could probably get away with if I wasn't
famous I could be like hey if the doors
open hey I gotta fix something you would
believe me a hundred percent right
so
the guy walks in and he says
which one you want
to Calvin
and I'm like oh hey just you do you want
one and he picks up a big ass dog I mean
it's this it's I mean it's it's this big
you know and he says you on this one and
I said do you like that buddy and Kevin
says yes
and I said you want that he says yes I
said yeah okay that one and he gives it
to Calvin I said can you say thank you
and Kevin says thank you and then the
guy says now I'm gonna take a nap and
goes like this
and just falls into all the stuffed
animals
and then buries himself in the stuffed
animals and closes the door and now you
can just win him I guess
so
and he's like buries himself to where he
stays there for a few seconds and then
peeks out and people who just walked up
are like what the [__] is happening I
got video of it I'll put it up on here
but it's so funny it's also on Instagram
on my reels page dude it's so funny to
see that dude that uh
is in there on the thing because you
know because of course it's funny
anyway uh well I was in Dave and
Buster's and uh we had a good time and
uh that's that but I'll tell you man I
was struggling the whole day man I was
just struggling the whole day just
trying to be there and then be cool with
it
um
we'll pissed you off about that day
think it yep I know dude I knew that
that was gonna happen I got the credit
for going to Sacramento because people
thought we were in Sacramento because we
were doing [__] dude yes I knew that was
gonna happen in that piss her off
because I got credit for but at last I
got the credit
hello
yeah the escalator I know it doesn't
matter what dude
I could say until I'm blue in the face I
wasn't in Sacramento there's still gonna
be people with that guy was in
Sacramento none of a good guy
yes dude he went to Sacramento didn't he
so uh so yeah so that's that's what's up
and I'm gonna have it you know and I'm
gonna have a new baby soon so so things
are all pointed in the right direction
I want to know uh if I know so the whole
thing about Trump being arrested
uh like it's just so not gonna happen
you know and I know if people are like
he's gonna get arrested and you know
he's even saying oh here they come I'm
getting arrested on you know [__]
Tuesday or whatever it's just not gonna
happen it's not ever gonna happen he
he's gonna die first and he's gonna live
a long time you know he's gonna live a
long time he does whatever the [__] he
wants that's the key to living a long
time doing whatever the [__] you want
within the confines of the law that's
what makes you live look my grandfather
lived he had no business live until 79
or whatever 78. the guy smoked since he
was [__] five years old
and just had no business dude and just
did because he did whatever he wanted
um and God bless people like that and uh
I used to be that way and I'm not now so
uh but anyway so um
so I'll die early so I
just won't live as long as I want to so
I so I hope you're happy now so I
did
uh but yeah so Trump's not gonna get
arrested he says he's gonna get arrested
and you know everybody makes internet
you know buzzing and he's not gonna get
arrested and it's okay
um
I I if he did
wow
you know
and that's my comment on that just I
can't even imagine a world where where'd
that happen in my life dude you know how
crazy [__] is right now imagine how
crazy it's gonna be in
uh uh 20 years
and thick [__] is going exponential
right but I I once I saw the thing in
Saudi Arabia that they're doing the
guy's paying 725 billion to do to make
the line or whatever it's called
to where it's like by the way I don't
whenever I
it's so annoying that America uses miles
and everyone else uses kilometers and
you got to like be like what is it but
it's like a hundred [__] something
miles of just two really large mirrors
that go up up up up up so high and you
could live in them
and it's like a tenth of a mile wide
and you can go up and down the line and
get anywhere from each point of the line
in 20 minutes
and you would be able to get anything
you need within five minutes
and it's like this futuristic thing
where nobody's gonna drive and you're
just gonna live on the line
and
that's how it's gonna be and they said
you can move in starting 2030 and it's
like okay but no you can't but then you
look into it and they already started
production dude okay
it has to fail
it's they're putting the quote is 725
billion dollars
dude they thought they were gonna
renovate the Ice House comedy club for
three million dollars I walked in the
other day there's no shot it was less
than 10.
no shot dude they got a VIP room just
like there's just no shot
and you're gonna make this line for 725
billion dollars no way a Saudi Prince or
whatever I get it of course you know
who's in the desert
I'm getting a spot I'm moving there dude
I'm opening up a comedy club on the line
hey how'd you wind up late everything
here you can get to in five minutes so
they say right yeah what do you live all
the way south of the line anyway
Just Clips popping off on tick tock
dude hashtag the line hashtag crowdwork
I'm the Saudi Arabian mad Rife
um
but yeah dude
so that's what's up
that's what's up and I you know and
frankly that's what's up I'm wearing my
shoes here
the Jordan Jordan 4 uh what the f-u-c-ks
my dad got him for me that's how cool he
is and um I really want the Jordan 4.
green SB
and I'm not gonna get him
why I don't know
I got rid of so much stuff because of
the purge because of the organizers came
in and it's so nice in here
but I really want those shoes but I
don't really wear fours but I digress
dude stockx got in a lot of trouble they
were saying that they were making fake
they were bringing out fakes they were
letting fake sneakers in and honestly
here's what I have to say about that I
don't care if I don't know the shoes are
fake and you got me for six bones you
got me
you got me for a rack you got me
right I don't know I guess it's
different because I have a lot of
followers on and so if they're gonna see
it and that oh like what's his name um
McLemore got
uh fake Red Octobers and people were
like he's got fake Red Octobers and then
he finally admitted the other day they
guys fake Red October and this is from
like a decade ago but uh
so he is uh you know if I had fake
shoots here's the deal I don't care if I
have fake shoes I don't I'd rather buy
the real ones if I'm gonna pay for it
obviously I'm not gonna buy I'd rather
buy real ones for the money than fake
ones for less money or I'd rather just
not get them than get the fake ones but
if you got me you got me dude and that's
fine I don't care don't tell me and then
if I'm posting about it and then people
are like you got fake ones and I don't
know about it that's the thing that I
get up that's the thing that I get upset
about it
right
so stockx apparently turned back now
they're trying to do all this reverse
press like well we turned back 100
million in fake uh product and it's like
first of all sounds too perfect 100
million but then it's like okay
so
you let some go through because you
gotta but go the I'm sure goat does and
all the other sneaker apps because it's
impossible to always check but what a
racket right what a racket to shoe
business is period like what a racket I
saw the new Vans coming out with the
lightning bolt forget it I want them
I want them so bad I'm gonna get every
color I'm gonna be a Vans guy now Vance
congratulations you did it the new light
with the lightning bolt dude they're so
sick look them up dude they're so sick
and I'm not a Vans guy dude I just throw
out one pair of Vans or pizza guy gaming
for me for free I don't wear them dude
but God those are sick you see them
with the backwards lightning bolts
oh put me in a body bag I'm done dude I
need those all four colors
over the blue one and the red one
together
um but yeah I'm a shoe guy you know but
man you should see my closet it's nice
as [__] I put on my store the other day
um
so I have to uh
oh wow my buddy just texted me and I'm
doing what I want responding to it
I'm doing what I want
um
so what else happened in the world man
did you have a thing did you put
anything on the documents that we could
talk about oh dude he did he came
equipped dude and that's that was just
me riffing and now I'm going to the
documents yeah I mean
oh yeah we did the house organizers dude
those ladies man those ladies came in
they're like awesome it's like they work
so quick and efficient here's the thing
too
I did did such a good job and I we paid
for it they did not do it free and I'm
not the kind of guy that's like hey give
me a deal because I'll post about dude
no that's horseshit when people want
free work for
like eyeballs
kiss my ass like no pay people for their
work
okay
look a lot of companies send me stuff
that you know and thank you I appreciate
you like to show this this uh place I
followed on Instagram row
r-o-u-h I don't know I think row is how
you pronounce it it's I think it's
overseas they got great t-shirts look
them up but um
they sent me stuff because I followed
them on Instagram they're like we're big
fans you know we're sending you send you
stuff so they sent me some stuff I wore
them my wife spilled coffee on the white
one we can't get it out all good but uh
brand new shirt it's fine but it's just
like
um
she did that
you know probably can't get it out it's
fine but the the the those shirts are
great and so that happens a lot and um
and so I I they did such a good job the
house organizers I was like this is very
visually appealing and I put on my
Instagram story
and I and I and I put it I tagged them
because I'm like they did such a good
job even though it costs racks and um
and I and I put it on my story and then
the lady responded of the who's the head
uh who's the company it is she was like
oh my God they said that you were so
good at getting rid of stuff that you
were the quickest purger they ever had
and I'm like okay well actually feels
kind of good you know I don't think
twice about throwing away a hoodie or
give it away you know I put it in the
either I gave it to uh uh
my friends or I also
give it to the Salvation Army I don't
know where they took it I said donated
but anyway my point is
uh she reposted it uh
honestly nine times to her story by
mistake and then took a screenshot of it
and then put it on the grid on her
Instagram and I'm like this is the the
this makes so much sense that the owner
of an organizing company made this
mistake right like I don't know what she
is I didn't look at her I'm sure she's a
white middle-aged woman and just posting
away just so many times I mean people
are just gonna be like what the [__] but
they did a great job and um
God it makes me feel good when my place
is clean when my house is clean my wife
it's like
just
it's just awesome
I care that the place is clean but not
enough to clean it
my wife when the [__] is clean
I think my wife floats
that's how much she can't get in a bad
mood if the place is nice she can't get
in a bad mood
I just period
like I could
I could go out and just start punching
people in the face
if I come back and the place isn't clean
she's like and she sees it on the news
she's like what the [__]
you can't just go out there and start
knocking people out
if I come home and the place is clean
and she sees it on the news she'll be
like Christopher you know you can't do
that look at the way they look at the
how
it's all with the shelves
it's unbelievable
she be loving a clean place man and I do
too it's nice but dude I'm not you know
I'm not doing cleaning
I did the dishes two days in a row and
it sucks man and only did it to make her
happy
but that's me dude I'm an empath
um
I guess Ted lasso
Jason Sudeikis was in the
sup with Ted lasso dude hey Ted lasso
sup never seen it friends on the show
creating making the show so happy for
all of their Emmy nominations
sup Ted lasso never seen it dude see so
many Billboards everywhere dude hey hey
what's up first of all I'll go on
further Apple TV
sup
right oh you got y'all you're fancy you
got the [__] Apple TV sup Apple TV
sup with the [__] new show Charlie
Hunnam oh what's up dude what are you
doing
sup
with the what's it called Shame a hammer
Raymond what's the [__] Charlie
Hunnam show called
shanamaram M Night shyamalam
what's it called
well you're finding out soon huh
shahama lamb
dude
here we go we're looking it up if I find
it first everyone's
shantaram dude Apple TV has the worst
titles for shows
Shannon
shantaram okay look at these look at
these out look at these Apple TV shows
Apple
TV
shows
here we go
these are not these are not Apple TV
show Plus shows Apple TV Plus shows
apple apple Originals there we go that's
how we do it
here we go
Apple Originals dude I get pissed off
because it's like cocaine bear the whale
and it's like it just shows you can
watch on the thing dude have you seen
cocaine bear
here's my review here's my review for
okay
they went for it they thought it was
funny so they shot it with the comedy of
mine all right dude you [__] up could
have made it way good all right here we
go although I'm a huge fan of uh what's
her name Elizabeth uh whoever the
director is
here are the names of the shows on Apple
the Apple TV
uh Originals these are the names just
let me I'm just gonna Argyle with two
L's sup
killers of the flower Moon
sup dude here's another one Swagger
stop dude that's a fake TV show in a
movie with Adam Sandler you know
here's another one uh
City on fire oh dude so basic here's
another one Silo that's okay the after
party that's okay ghosted
here's another one drops of God
oh stop
the last thing he told me dude here's
another one Jane oh
Hoda
here's another one Mega Dunes stop
come on man
come on with these names ex oh dude
extrap extrapolations
stop
I mean come on dude even this is the
problem with Jon Stewart sup dude that's
so something that will come in 2003.
dude come on man
here's another one liaison dude here's
another one The Reluctant Traveler
dude are you kidding here's another one
hello tomorrow
sup this is just so these names are so
awful how they're doing it
and these aren't even kid shows sharper
dear Edward
operation trade bomb
Little America dude come on man and then
the worst show that was ever created in
the world carpool karaoke
the history of the world
carpool karaoke and that's counting
the shows the commish and the hat Squad
those are two shows that are real that
have been in history and the worst show
of all time is carpool karaoke this
series hey
sup dude guys just piling a car and you
sing hits hey but you're Sam Jackson hey
but you're Brie Larson hey you got no
business singing
but they just walk in and they're just
like 500 25 600 minutes anyway go see
Captain Marvel hey but
hey but I mean make bet Mythic Quest sup
these move these show the names of them
they're unbelievable all right we're
done here you know it's like I don't
know what you want from me but
uh uh telesto was at the [__] white
house and it's just like what's going on
right
how much of a I've never I've never met
him I met him once Jason Sudeikis
and they were like uh it was at The
Comedy Store years ago and they were
like hey he wants to run his thing that
he's doing at the Oscars that's funny or
something or his hosting thing and the
guy was like all right you can go up
after kristalia he was like okay and I
got off stage and just [__] leveled
the place and I say hey have fun oh wait
no he [__] actually left now that I
remember he left he didn't go on because
your boy leveled up I go oh he's gonna
come up okay
okay
no I want everyone to do stand up I want
people who don't do stand up to go on
stage and do stand up I want them to
favors
I want you to go on I want you go on
after go on before I don't care go on
after me I'm not doing any favors go on
before me
they're gonna go like this afterwards
who was the guy that went on before
Chris
ah
when I go on stage and there's someone
before me dude it's like Men In Black
showed up flunk
that's it
anyway
thanks for listening that was the
episode get your tickets at
crystallia.com Milwaukee Minnesota
Austin you know all the other places
Midland I feel like I've been saying
Midland for nine years uh Ohio and all
the different places go to chrisley.com
Salt Lake City can't wait that's almost
sold out other ones are almost sold out
other ones are sold out go get your
tickets chrisley.com thank you very much
like And subscribe and leave a comment
do it pump that I'll go that's it that's
the end of the show if you want to watch
the rest of the show The uncut episode
go on over to patreon.com that's it for
YouTube you can get the extended version
at patreon.com crystalia and you can
also get uh there's like 25 extra
episodes that are available as soon as
you unlock it for six dollars
patreon.com uh Slash chrysalia thanks a
lot uh I appreciate you
[Music]
thank you